non devo registrare proviene ma non devo
5 driver simulator vedete di ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo un video sono pani
generi siamo appunto su draghi tyler
simulator che rende orgoglioso i miei
genitori del mio lavoro
allora questa è la demo è gratis il
gioco ufficiale c'è non so come perché
ho detto che non mi sposerò avevamo la
demo che secondo me ancora fattibile
vediamo che cacchio han tirato fuori sta
roba perché io non me ne intendo però
qualcuno mi spiega cos'è che dovrei fare
vedo che almeno la casa dove vivo e in
ordine fattibile java a fuoco la roba
drag dealer simulator signori siamo nel
bronx
credo in america adrian salas mille
scrisse ho trovato le chiavi let's go
andiamo a vedere un po di animal
crossing la madonna broken brain meno
male che vivo all'ultimo piano dove la
gente sicuro non fa brutto perché non
c'è la gente non ci arriva fino a qua e
joey de curva view curva in rumeno
significava chicca prato fuori che
questo rumore disturbo acustico che
fastidio la madonna quanto fatto bene
sto gioco salve vuole un po di animal
crossing che cielo qua per lei si fermi
che io qua vendo a domicilio non allora
sono tipo derive ruderi mostruosi devo
capire gomez è di rockol square perché
effettivamente io le devo prendere la
roma prima di rivenderla è tutto un tipo
skyrim magari bello come vedo che una
città che rispetta le regole di tutto
questo è una pala eolica schiantata sei
tu e di non penso fosse di quello eccolo
è di come ho fatto a non veder di
chiarirlo chivu di grace già nel proprio
a spiegarmi cosa devo fare io sono
astemio c'è un fumone ne bevono faccio
una storia di chiaro che ora andiamo
dietro lo supermarket come siccome ci si
alza qua ciao vado dietro supermarket
perché devo raccogliere la roba che non
mi ha lasciato prendi questo secolo
mentre gli uffici e merchandise come the
job wall vent stavano nelle costava ma
dai ma dai ma dai tre pacchi in vari
luoghi grossi lo trovate
ora andiamo dai nostri primi tre clienti
ok bastavano nel corso dell'evento le
inventano tutte salve vuole un po di
animal crossing da mi ha detto delfino
ma lei un gamer bella a tutti i ragazzi
sono damien delpino e voglio un po di
marijuana skate
la partita che non ti ho detto ha dato
niente notato niente bene stratos ovvero
lei e il signor kacha pukha panca eccoci
translation a perché ci sono i rischi
delle transazioni perché magari uno in
borghese non posso dargli lì perché non
posso aspetto aspettare non posso non
posso portarmi troppi soldi dietro ma
come allo specchio a depositarli in
ottimi sa cosa vuol dire ma cove chiuso
a casa mia e casinò la vita da george
diller backpack a roveri ho preso il
back to back
adesso posso occupare più prendere più
soldi perché col backpack giustamente
signore ha dei bellissimi pantaloni e
dov'eravamo rimasti adesso c'è un back
che posso fare gli angresi che non tutto
con tutto solo 11 solo rai 90 respect
city square city square eccolo qua drag
package qua devo andare lì quindi lì c'è
il mio pecchia la madonna richiesta
tomba santo iddio
ok allora devo trovare perché ogni volta
che vado in dei posti io non mi viene
detto dove la roba la devo trovare io
devo essere furbo non sono così esperto
di trovarobe nascoste però vediamo la
teoricamente dovrebbe essere qui dentro
se non erro perché me la dà proprio qui
però magari mi sbaglio io il difficile
proprio il difficile visto gioco e
trovare la roma nascosta perché per
portarti alla tela nascondono maghi che
ne so io dove è di dove melai ficcata
attenzione l'ho trovata solo un esperto
10 mag di parigi sono più polizia nelle
nelle strade attenzioni a fare occhio
ragazzi questo il momento difficile del
gioco ho fatto bene a non comprarlo sto
gioco
eppure scaricatissimo su steve è uno dei
giochi che va di più nell'ultimo mese
tra l'altro negli ultimi due mesi forze
ci sono un po di spray
credo che la città è ben curata ben
pulita meno male fa piacere sciupa
pancreas
come stai eri dei quali jean fetta min 3
grammi led che non tutta non tutta di 3
grammi 3 grammi 3 grammi troppa roba
questa trenti qua fai 3 g 33 grammi
non devo usare la work station per per
sfruttarla perché non lo posso fare così
ok scuse ora specchi attorno
devo usare arriva arriva riva arrivare
preoccupati per utilizzare la mia work
station per per sfruttare lo zucchero
perché lo zucchero non lo puoi stare
davanti al cliente sex slate madonna
casi non hanno fatto in bordella tissimo
non si capisce una sega cosa devo fare
per repesa prendili new parcheggi sono
tre total mas 3 quindi il nuovo
pacchetto da 33 quantity 1 ha detto
inventori o santo iddio cosa stiamo
sbagliando prima saving jolo gay meno
salvo niente non sanno niente perché mi
fido nessuno mi piglia signor da il pino
arrivo del pino eccolo lì sennò delpino
ci ho messo due ore voglio degli extra
che fanno paura
porco demonio per accontentare lei
arcavacata
grazie prego ci ha messo un'ora e mezza
di dio c'è ancora harry e sciupa campo
in fondo se non vuole le lingue crossing
il signor chupacabra teoricamente
dovremmo aver fatto speriamo che voglia
la buona lena crossing la fanteria
bisogno di qualcosa ha tolto senza audio
aveva presentati dopo un po di package
ma con gli ho dato della roba non voleva
neanche un passante quello a cosa c'è da
ragazzi incredibile l'aveva non ha un
senso sto gioco comunque tutto ciò cosa
che mi dice marco de terry marca al
territorio come lo marco con la
bomboletta spray usa lo usa la
bomboletta spray come la come la uso io
veramente non so poi anche due ore ci
metta sbagliarlo è quello il fatto
incredibile bellissima più respect va
bene e quindi va bene ragazzi vedo che
comunque questo c'è nel senso potrebbero
avanti tutto il giorno ma non è non è il
caso
spero che vi sia piaciuto questo era
drag dealer simulator gioco di steam
vendutissimo degli ultimi due mesi tra
l'altro board se proprio vi sia piaciuto
iscritti al canale per gli altri lo come
questi e noi ci vediamo e vedrete vi
piace
non so cosa dire spero che non nessuno
vedere da questo video ma non vedrà
nessuno
niente ci siamo ragazzi
[Musica]